Where's the editing tutorial?
>> How do you edit?
>> Bro, are you using Adobe to edit your
videos? You edit so good.
>> Where do you edit videos?
>> How do you edit your videos?
>> Where's the tutorial video?
>> tutorial
>> Yep, this is the editing tutorial. But
why the hell did it take 9 months to
make it? Well, it all started 1 year
ago.
An editing tutorial from me? Really?
>> Why not? Have you ever checked your
views? People love your videos, man.
>> Look, I know a thing or two about
editing, but making a tutorial, there
are freaking editing wizards out there
making stuff I can't even imagine. I
mean, look at this guy. How the hell
does he do that? The best I can do is
how to edit slightly above average
tutorial.
>> And isn't that the point? You don't need
to be an editing wizard, you just need
to be you. Someone who's been through
the journey.
>> What do you mean?
>> Remember your early days, man. You knew
nothing about editing. I've been there.
>> Wait, you were there?
>> I mean, for the most part.
>> Oh.
>> Everything you know, you learned the
hard way. Wouldn't you want someone to
guide you through that path back then?
>> Yeah.
>> Just keep it real. Show the way for past
Isaac. How you edit your videos from
start until the end. The stuff you
learned along the way. And hey, who
knows? Maybe I'll send it back to him.
>> All right.
>> That's my man.
>> But if I'm doing this, I'm making the
best editing tutorial YouTube has ever
seen.
>> Yeah, I know. You've probably heard this
a million times and rolling your eyes.
But different audiences want different
editing. You can't use a Mr. Beast style
editing in a Ruhi video. It just doesn't
feel right. Now, every editing tutorial
is saying this exact same thing. But the
problem is all of them proceed to
explain both editing styles in theory
and never actually give you practical
advice. You know why? Because they don't
want to lose the other side of their
views. It's all about keeping the
retention high. I know it's not a wise
choice for retention, but I don't want
to be one of them. I want to actually
teach you something. So, instead of
juggling two different editing styles
and giving random tips from each one,
let's pick the one that I'm better at,
which is fancy editing. The editing like
this and this and this.
I want you to walk away from this
tutorial actually knowing how to edit,
not watching another video that explains
the same theory for the hundredth time.
You wouldn't want to sit down to edit
and realize halfway through that your
script isn't good enough. Or even worse,
the video idea doesn't make sense. If
you want to edit viral videos,
everything else should be made with that
in mind as well. An amazing edit can't
save a boring script or a bad video
idea. So, let's quickly fix these at
first.
Think about your target audience. Is the
idea interesting for them? Would someone
click on this video if they didn't know
you?
I already covered it in another video.
For the script, start by outlining all
the points you want to cover in the
video and write everything that's on
your mind. Most YouTubers stop here, but
after writing everything, I always come
up with a secondary story. Something
deep, almost like a short film that runs
alongside the main video. After that,
create a structure. Cut out useless
parts. Ask ChatGPT to make it easier to
understand and build some kind of
progress from the start until the end of
your video. We're going to dive a lot
deeper into scripting in a future video,
so I'll not waste much time on that
here.
Just record your voice on a microphone
or like me, use an AI voice generator
like Eleven Labs. Create a voice and
paste everything in your script but
little little into the middle. Some
people still think that AI voices are
too robotic. But trust me, it has
improved a lot. I mean, I can get random
emotions like
see?
You can check out Eleven Labs with the
link in description. It's not sponsored
by the way. I just get a small
commission if you use my link and it's a
great tool.
Sorry. Okay, let's move on.
Here's the thing about filming. I have
absolutely no clue. I get all my footage
from the internet. So, yeah.
Look at other YouTubers videos but even
better, watch a good movie before
editing.
Just a heads up, don't watch five
seasons of Breaking Bad just to get
inspired for one video. Don't ask me how
I know. With all the rise of short-form
content, some people haven't even sat
and watched a two-hour-long movie in
year. But if you find any type of movie
that you like and watch it with your
editor's eye, you'll get so much
inspiration that you can't even make
that much video. Transition,
storytelling, montages, camera angles,
you name it. Most of this stuff hasn't
even been implemented once on YouTube
yet. So, you want originality? This is
where you get them. Even though it's not
going to be as good as a masterpiece
like Morbius, you're making your own
movies. Once these are ready, move on to
the next step.
When I say assets, I'm talking about
music, sound effects, overlays, and
presets. It takes hundreds of trial and
error to find the right ones. But if you
don't have time for that, I put together
all the assets I used to edit my videos.
Here's where I get them from.
Now, this part may seem a bit
unnecessary but it made everything way
faster for me in the actual editing.
Take your script and color code what's
happening in each sentence. I like to
divide it into six categories but you
can adjust this based on your style.
Once you're done with the entire script,
collect all the elements you need for
each part. I marked this part as a
screen record. So, now I'll gather all
the screen recordings for this section.
The same process for images, videos, and
everything else. And for the animations,
uh just keep it there. I'm going to
explain it in a few minutes. After you
went through the entire script and got
everything you need, you're ready to
move on to
All right, finally, it's time to open
Premiere Pro. Click create a new
project, create again, and add a new
sequence. I like to make my videos in
1920 by 1080, which is high enough so no
one's counting pixels and low enough to
not burn my computer. Though you can use
4K if you got a beast in your house. Oh,
and 60 FPS.
Create your workplace by dragging
windows around, however you're
comfortable with. Personally, I like
this layout with the main video in the
center, timeline at the bottom, footage
and effects here, effect controls and
raw footage monitor here. If you're
missing any windows, just enable them
from the menu here.
Next up, import your voiceover. Drag to
the timeline, cut it based on the
script, and remove any awkward pauses or
moments where it drags the flow.
Okay, this one might not fit for
everyone's workflow, but I like adding
the music right after the voiceover. I
know, most editors save it for the end,
but I think it gives more clarity on the
vibe you're going for in the entire
edit. Plus, it lets you make cuts based
on the beat. And most importantly, it's
more fun. So, where to find good music?
I used to grab no copyright music from
YouTube for a long time. But lately,
I've been hooked on Epidemic Sound. It's
just more convenient to find music and
sound effects based on every detail, and
you don't need to worry about copyright
issues. One thing I didn't realize until
editing this video is that you can copy
and paste your favorite songs from
Spotify and get similar music. I mean,
what the hell? Why didn't anyone told me
that? Once you've got your music, drop
it to the timeline and adjust the volume
based on the voiceover.
Now comes the fun part. Remember the
highlights on the script? Start layering
in all your videos, images, and screen
recordings based on the highlights. It's
not necessary if you're new to editing,
but it's a good idea to experiment with
some cuts based on the music beats. It
gives your edit that extra punch and
keeps it flowing easier. Another little
trick I like to use is just plain text
on a black background, just like I'm
doing right now. We're going to dive
into text in a minute, so leave it blank
for now. Okay? Looking good so far? But
remember, you highlighted one more thing
in your script.
Animations. All right, here's the truth.
Animation is not as easy as it looks,
especially if it's your first time. But
don't worry, we'll break it down
together.
So, in the script that you highlighted,
let's take the first animation. I'm just
going to take a cool one from my
previous video. In this video, I'll
focus on the short-form content, how you
can get similar views as quickly as
possible, and show you the exact method
I use to make them go viral.
Grab a pen and paper and imagine the
animation. You're probably thinking of
something that walks the viewer through
the method step-by-step, right? Picture
this. We'll have some boxes connected to
each other by arrow, like a flowchart.
Inside each box is a heading, but
they're blurred out for now. Then we'll
we'll zoom into the first box, and boom,
the text is revealed. That's a solid
one. Let's create it.
Now, there are two ways to create the
animations, easy way and hard way. Let's
start with the first one. If your
animation is too simple and not much
fancy stuff is going on, you can create
it in Canva. I made my first video's
animations using only Canva. Just create
the animation you sketched with shapes,
text, and graphics. For our example, it
might look something like this. Once
you've got your design set, add some
animations.
And that's it.
Keep in mind, if you want to add some
zoom-ins to them in the edit, export the
video in a higher quality, or it may
look like this.
That works for simple animation, but if
you want to edit like a pro, it's time
to dive into After Effects.
But here's your warning. This route gets
much more complex than Canva, so it's
okay to freak out if it's your first
time using. Every editor has been there.
Honestly, I think I'm still freaking out
each time I see it. Oh,
There's too much detail to explain
here, so I'm going to do a separate
video for creating more complex
animations in the future. But, the idea
is the same as Canva. Use tools like
text,
shapes,
or pen to create the base of your
animation. Once you have something
similar to your sketch, adjust them
based on the voice-over. Add typewriter
animation to texts and trim paths to
move shapes.
Lastly, add some glow effect to make
them pop. At least that's what I do. It
takes more time, but the result is
next-level.
You can repeat the same process for all
the other animations as well. Sketch,
create, animate. Until I make the full
animation tutorial, if you want to do
some research yourself, I shared some
keywords and tutorials from other
creators that might help.
And once all the animations are ready,
drop them to the timeline as well. Line
them up with your voice-over and we're
one step closer to a polished final
edit.
By now, your timeline should be looking
pretty solid. But, here's the thing, the
first rough cut is never perfect. So, if
you have time, go back and watch it
again. Trust me, you'll spot points to
improve. Add extra animations, screen
recordings, some funny memes. Sometimes
I even rewrite parts of the script if a
better idea pops in my head. But, it's
not about just adding things. At some
point, you'll need to cut off useless
parts. Look out for boring lines in the
script, unnecessary footage, or bad
jokes. Cut everything that doesn't serve
the video's main goal. And yeah, I only
keep the good jokes. You wouldn't want
to see the bad ones.
Don't Hey, don't show it. So, you added
new stuff, removed useless stuff, but
that's still not enough. There's one
more thing you need, space. I know, I
know. You always heard that people's
attention span is shorter than a
jellyfish, and if you want to make a
viral video, you've got to keep up the
pace. Get to the point as fast as
possible and move on to the next because
if you slow down for too long, you're
going to be
boring.
So, cut every single millisecond where
something interesting isn't. Dry
people's dopamine, make them hate their
life after watching this video, and
maximize your retention.
But, here's the twist. Cutting every
space may mean cutting the actual story
from your video. So, how do you balance
it? The best way to summarize this point
is people don't have shorter attention
spans, they just have higher standards.
So, make the stop worth waiting for.
All right, we're done with the boring
parts. Now, it's time to get our hands
dirty. Before we dive in, just remember
this, good editing doesn't mean using as
many effects as you can. It means using
it to complement what's being said in
the video. So, you need to resist the
urge to throw in every flashy thing you
find in the effects tab.
Sometimes you need to zoom in and out to
highlight something on the screen or
just to add a little movement to your
video. To do that, use a transform
effect. Add scale and position key
frames to the start, move forward in the
timeline, and adjust where you want the
zoom to end.
Sure, it gets the job done, but it's not
smooth at all. To make it flow better,
expand the effect and make the curves
smoother.
Much better. Well, that's basic
knowledge. To take it further, you need
to keep the point of focus consistent in
between cuts. This keeps the viewers'
eyes from wandering all over the place
and makes it easier to watch. To do
that, use guides, center point, eye
line, but my favorite is the rule of
thirds. The idea is that the main focus
of each zoom and cut must stay at the
same spot, like this.
Text in videos is a subjective choice.
Some people never use it, some use it
all over the place. Personally, I use it
in three places.
Captions are the most obvious one, but I
try not to slap them all over the video
because it can become irritating to see
a text pop every second throughout the
entire time. So, I use it where I talk
about something important.
Center text is for moments where
captions aren't enough. It can have its
own color, glow, or whatever makes it
pop.
And then, there's text that becomes a
part of the scene, attached to a screen,
a wall, or something in the background.
Now, how do you actually create these?
It's simple. Click this text tool, click
on the video, type something, and adjust
its settings in the effect controls to
match your channel's brand.
To give it a pop animation like you see
in my videos, we're going to use the
ancient technique of Sensei Finzar. Take
the transform effect, add it to the
text, set a scale key frame at the start
around 70%, then move about seven frames
forward, increase the scale to 110%,
move forward another five frames, and
bring it back to 100.
I smooth out the key frames, but there
isn't a big difference. Also add glow,
glitch, or whatever else fits your
style. Repeat the same for other texts
as well. Looking good. To save time in
the future, select your text and
animations, right click, and save as a
preset. Next time you can just drag and
drop that preset to a text box, and
you're done.
Obviously, using a character isn't a
must. So, if you don't use it, just skip
this part. But if you do, here's the
process. Create a head or a logo with an
AI image generator. I have a video
diving deeper into this matter if you're
interested. Once you got something you
like, slap it onto a stock image, export
the image, and add it to your video.
Again, use key frames to move it around,
smooth out the key frames, same stuff.
And, of course, create presets to use it
next time. By the way, if you're looking
to save time with some of these effects,
I put together a few of my presets for
free. Links in the description if you
want to check them out.
You've probably noticed those fancy
electric effects, dust, light leaks, and
other textures throughout the video.
They're called overlays. Basically, a
video with black background, so that you
can change the display mode to screen
and make it transparent. You can use
them as highlighters, transitions, or
just to make your video fancy.
I mostly use light leaks for
transitions, but there are some preset
packs for changing in between scenes,
like slides, shakes, zooms, rotations,
and things like that.
I don't go too heavy on effects, but
when I do, my go-to options are glow, 3D
transform, blur, mosaic, and things like
that.
At this point, I get it. You're probably
overwhelmed by the things you have to
learn to make a single video. That's
normal. But, here's the secret. You
don't have to learn everything at once.
Just pick one small thing from this
tutorial and try it in your next video.
Practice until you're decent at it, then
take another, then another, then
another, and repeat. Nobody is chasing
you.
Now, keep in mind, just because you can
use an effect or a transition doesn't
mean you should. Sometimes keeping
things simple is more effective than
using every single effect you can.
But, no matter how great your edit turns
out, without proper sound effects
underneath, the video will feel flat,
and viewers will sense something's
missing. There are three main types of
sound effects: whoosh, riser, and
impact. These are the basics, so don't
limit yourself. Based on your video, you
can throw in keyboard sounds, gears,
memes, clicks, bomb clock, pretty much
anything you can come up with. You can
find all kinds of sound effects from
YouTube and paid platforms like Epidemic
Sound. I use a combination of both. Now,
the technique I found that makes the
process easier is just mute all the
other audio tracks. Watch the video and
add the sound effects you think would
fit best. May sound obvious, but when I
started, I was doing my sound designs
with voice-over and music enabled. It
wasn't good. And don't be afraid to
experiment and combine different sound
effects together. It may feel too
time-consuming and unnecessary since you
can't see anything visually changing in
the video, but sound design is literally
half of the video. So, it's definitely
worth investing time on that part. And
finally, lower the volume of the sounds
so that they don't become annoying.
We're almost done, but the colors look a
bit off. To fix that, add a Lumetri
color effect on each clip and change the
exposure, contrast, saturation, and
things like that.
All right. So, mastering the basics and
improving in all those skills with every
video is essential, but here's where a
lot of channels fail. They don't try
anything new. You know the channels
where each video feels like the exact
same copy of the last 10, and that's the
recipe for failure. Now, I have to admit
something. I still don't know 90% of the
stuff in editing, and neither does
anyone else. But, the key is, are you
learning with every video? If you keep
trying new things each time, and that
gap between what you know and what you
don't know will slowly get smaller.
Sure, it will never go down to zero, but
that's the point. Most people are stuck
here forever, and even if you're here,
you can overtake them just by learning
with each video, because most people
don't even try.
Editing isn't just what you see in
tutorials. There's so much out there you
can improvise or learn from others. For
every video I make, I try something new
that I could not do until that point.
For my first video, I didn't know how to
make animations, so I tried making
crappy animations with Canva. For the
second one, I tried these electricity
effects. Next, I used After Effects for
the first time and tried creating an
entire storyline. The list goes on for
every single video. That's why these
videos take so much time to create.
Sometimes I spend 3 hours learning a new
technique to use in a 5-second part of
my video. Most editors just do what they
already know to be more efficient, but
if you invest 3 hours to learn that new
effect, the next time that 3 hours will
become 1 hour, then 30 minutes, 10
minutes, and just a few minutes, and
once an impossible effect will become an
ordinary thing. That's how I learned to
edit better.
Sounds cool, right? But, sometimes
well, most of the times, things don't go
as planned.
>> How's the masterpiece coming along?
>> Almost done. Just adding some final
touches, you know, little details to
make it perfect.
>> Dude, you said the same thing last week
and the week before.
>> Just a few more tweaks, okay? Trust me,
it's going to be the ultimate tutorial.
>> All right, man. But, remember, sometimes
done is better than perfect.
>> Ugh, you sound like an AI-generated
motivational video.
>> Just don't get lost in details, okay?
>> don't worry about me.
So, I kept editing, applied everything I
learned, even researched new techniques
to take my video a step further. Every
day, it felt like the video was getting
better and better. But, after a while,
something started to feel wrong.
What the is going on?
Almost 60 days had passed and I was
still editing the same video.
>> Want to grab some drink?
>> It It feels like I'm stuck in a loop
that will never end. What should I do?
Isn't there a tutorial for this?
>> I mean, you're the one that's making
tutorials here.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, I've been watching you since
the beginning of your journey. Do you
know what your weakness is? And you
think that you can learn everything just
by watching a tutorial about it. But,
there isn't a tutorial for this.
>> So, am I going to stuck here?
>> Look, I'm not an editor, but let me tell
you what I know. That's the thing about
anything creative you do. It's never
done. You can always improve it. Add a
new effect, create a better animation,
find better music, tell a better story.
It's a cycle that never ends.
>> So,
how do I escape?
>> Maybe you just need to say it's good
enough.
>> It's good enough.
>> Take a deep breath.
And press publish.
>> Yeah, I still couldn't fully overcome my
perfectionism.
But, I'm trying my best. Even if it's
not flawless, it's still going to help
someone out there.
>> More than you know. Sometimes it's
better to see the process, not only the
right things, but the mistakes as well.
That's what makes it
Dude, I didn't finish my motivational
speech.
>> Don't worry, they get it.
>> All right.
>> I know some of you were probably
expecting some kind of secret technique
that I used to make my edits stand out.
While making this video, I thought about
this a lot, but the truth is such a
technique doesn't exist. I can't fully
explain how I edited those videos. The
only technique was to keep learning new
things each time. Combine different
styles, draw inspirations, break the
rules, and add something from you.